okay um
okay
so um hi everyone welcome back to the
um to the uh afternoon session so we'll
have two very exciting talks the first
one will be given by c for chewie uh
who's a phd at mit of philippi
and he will uh tell us about the
improved image independence for mala and
overall
so stimulus
hey uh hi everyone i'm
and today i'll be talking about uh
improved dimension dependence for mala
and lower bounds for sampling
so this is all uh joint work with my
wonderful collaborators kongjun on
patrick derber chen liu jiang chang
and philippe are all here at simon's
right so
one of the reasons why researchers are
so interested in sampling nowadays is
because there's this amazing connection
between the fields of optimization and
sampling namely in optimization what we
want to do is we want to optimize an
objective function f and in sampling we
want to sample from a target
distribution pi
so throughout this talk
pi is always going to have a density e
to the minus v on rd
and this this function v is called the
potential of the distribution and it's
analogous to the objective function in
optimization
so inspired by this connection
researchers have on one hand try to
bring in the extensive toolkit of
reliable algorithms from optimization to
the world of sampling for instance
optimization has all these algorithms
such as gradient descent mirror descent
proximal gradient descent i could even
add to this accelerated gradient to send
coordinate descent and for each of these
algorithms that i just mentioned
we now have a sampling analog of it so
we have longevan mir longivan and so
forth so this part of the story where we
try to bring in algorithms from
optimization to the sampling problem has
been largely a success story and one
that's still ongoing
on the other hand there's another aspect
of optimization
which is that it has a very refined
non-asymptotic theory of complexity and
the analogous story for sampling is
still much less understood and this is
sort of what my talk is going to focus
on
let's start by formulating this
complexity question a little more
precisely
okay so the the notion of complexity i'm
i'm considering in this talk is that of
query complexity okay so i'm going to
allow you to make queries to the
potential v and also its gradient grad v
and we want to know how many queries are
required
to this oracle in order to output
approximate sample from the target
distribution
okay so in this talk i'm mostly going to
focus on sort of the
the simplest the most canonical case
which is that i'm going to assume that
this potential is strongly convex and
smooth and kappa is going to denote its
condition number
so what we want is we want a description
of this of the complexity of sampling
from this class of distributions in
terms of the relevant parameters of the
problem which are the dimension the
condition number the accuracy epsilon
and so forth and i haven't yet specified
what metric we're looking at but you can
think like uh this question is
interesting for any of the standard
metrics that we look at total variation
vessel stein etc
okay so so this is going to be the
complexity question we looked at today
and a quick outline of what my talk is
going to focus on first i'm going to
look at this complexity problem from an
upper bound standpoint
so i'm going to try to really understand
the complexity of one family of
algorithms namely the family of
metropolis suggested algorithms
we're going to see that this family of
algorithms is very interesting to
study for many reasons it's a widely
used in practice it's sort of the key to
unlocking high accuracy guarantees for
sampling yet it's much less understood
than their counterparts which are
algorithms based on discretizations of
stochastic processes
so after really spending most of my time
on on like how we can understand better
understand the complexity of this
particular algorithm in the last part of
my talk i'll just briefly
describe what we could say about more
general sampling algorithms
all right let's jump right into it what
is a metropolis hastings algorithm
so a metropolis hastings algorithm
proceeds by first initializing a point
drawn from the initial distribution mu
zero and at each step we're going to
repeat these two two steps first we're
going to propose a new point y n plus
one from some uh probability kernel this
is called the proposal kernel
and this kernel is something that i'm
allowed to choose as part of my
algorithm
then we take this proposed point and we
accept it with some probability that's
written here
and just to be clear about what i mean
if we accept
then what that means is that the next
item of our algorithm is going to be the
proposed point yn plus one
otherwise if we don't accept
then the next iterate of our algorithm
is just the previous iterate
okay so
the nice thing about this
this acceptor jack step is that really
like no matter what the proposal kernel
is
this except project step will ensure
that the stationary distribution of this
markov chain is going to be the correct
one pi
this allows us for great flexibility in
choosing what this proposal kernel
should be and of course like the better
that our kernel is suited to this
sampling problem the better the
resulting algorithm is going to become
so let's see some examples of
these metropolis hastings algorithms
so the the first example is almost the
simplest thing you could do which is i
if i'm at a point x i'm just going to
propose a gaussian which is centered at
my current points i'm really just doing
a complete random walk on my state space
occasionally accepting or rejecting my
points that's a metropolis random walk
of course you could do something a
little bit smarter which is uh this
metropolis suggested langevan algorithm
or mala which now uses uh gradient
information
to constructed steps
so where mala comes from
is that this kernel is one step
of discretization
of the land driven process
okay so
as many of you know the language process
is a continuous time stochastic process
whose stationary distribution is pi
and this is
uh given by one step of a discretization
of this stochastic process
now once once you discretize the
stochastic process you're going to
introduce bias
so the stationary distribution of the
discretized process is no longer equal
to pi
so what this algorithm is saying is okay
we we discretize but then now we add
this extra filtering step
in order to correct for this bias and
return us to the correct stationary
distribution
so that's mala
you can consider more complicated things
for instance um
here we have a metropolis hmc where the
proposal is given by k steps of a
leapfrog integrator of the continuous
time
hamiltonian dynamics
so i won't talk much about hmc in this
talk but i just want to note here that
the case of k equals one step
corresponds precisely back to ma
okay so what what can we say about these
algorithms
so the good news is as i mentioned
before this filtering step automatically
ensures we have we have the correct
stationary distribution
now if you have a markov chain with the
correct stationary distribution you can
kind of expect it under general
circumstances to converge geometrically
to its stationary distribution hence we
get a very good dependence on the
accuracy parameter we we usually get
poly log one over epsilon dependence on
the accuracy
this should be in contrast with
discretizations of stochastic processes
which usually get more on the lines of
poly one over epsilon dependence
so
these metropolis cases filters are
really are key to getting high accuracy
guarantees for example
and they're extremely widely used in
practice
however they're actually much less
understood than discretizations of
stochastic processes and that's really
because in the definition of the
algorithm we accept certain steps with
with a certain probability
and to
understand the performance of this
algorithm we kind of need to control
this acceptance probability but it's not
very clear how we can best do this
so what what sort of known
non-asymptotically about this family of
algorithms
so these these are the state of the
result state of the art results that i'm
aware of all these rates here i'm
showing are just under the assumptions
that i listed at the beginning of my
talk just strong convexity and
smoothness so if you assume like more
assumptions you could get better rates
but this is sort of the state of the art
now one thing i want you to notice here
is that okay
you can like improve the condition
number dependence a little bit
but all of these rates are bottlenecked
at d dimension dependence which is quite
large
if you think about it
it's kind of curious because metropolis
random walk it's doing the most naive
thing possible just a complete random
walk on my state space accept or reject
occasionally
mala is using gradient information so
it's smarter and hmc is more
sophisticated yet however all of these
just get d dimension dependence
so is this fundamental are we missing
something here
of course you can look at any upper
bound rate and ask if it can be improved
but do i actually have a reason for
believing that these rates can be
improved
okay so there's this uh classical
literature which i'm going to refer to
as the diffusion scaling heuristic and
this goes back to roberts and rosenthal
in 98.
this is what they showed
if you run mala with a target
distribution being a product
distribution and you choose the step
size to scale with the with the
dimension i'm going to choose the
explicit scaling l over d to the one
third for this step size
then you can consider the high
dimensional limit as as the dimension d
tends to infinity
and it turns out that the algorithm mala
converges to an infinite dimensional
langevin diffusion with a certain speed
which is explicitly given in terms of
this l
okay and the speed is a non-trivial
okay so this result assumes more than uh
what i described at the beginning of my
talk it requires like some more uh
higher order regularity on v in
particular like you need some
some bounds on the third derivative of b
but anyway what is the takeaway of this
result
well
if step size one over d to the one third
leads you to a non-trivial limit process
then they concluded that the dimension
dependence of mala under in this setting
should actually be d to the one third
okay and uh i'll just mention like one
reason why this this work has been so
influential is because
it gave very specific actionable advice
to practitioners on how best to choose
the step size of model
okay but as you can see there's there's
quite a gap between this line of work
which gets d to the one-third and the
best non-asymptotic results which were
all the way up at d
so
you know some natural questions that
arise from this are like is this
improved rate an artifact of the fact
that we're looking at some kind of
asymptotic regime like what can we
improve our non-asymptotic rates and and
so forth
so now i'm going to describe our our
main result which gets somewhere in
between
okay and this is what it says we have an
additional assumption
which is a warm start condition that is
you need to initialize mala at a
distribution mu zero
which is not too far away from the
target distribution pi in the sense that
this density ratio is uniformly bounded
and then
under this kind of assumption we we
obtain an improved mixing time bound for
molar which now scales as square root d
times polynomial factors in the
condition number in log one over epsilon
and we can get this result in any of the
standard metrics tv w2 kl chi squared
and so forth
okay so the next part of my talk i'm
going to kind of dive into the technical
details of this result so before that
this would be a good chance to answer
any questions about the setting
yeah so empirically like for a nice
distributions you do observe this due to
the one-third behavior
although i should say like
the experiments are more about the
acceptance probability
so you you scale the step size one over
d to the one-third and you see that
you're
accepting most of your steps and that
like heuristically tells you that this
is a a good step size choice to to make
it's a bit harder to like test
experimentally what the the mixing time
is yeah so the warm start is it easy to
construct or
you just assume it
no so the warm start is an issue and i i
want to like get back to this point
later
so what do you currently have if you are
uh if you just you should just fit it by
a gaussian
you can enter the one step yes if you
remove wormstar and replace that if you
start with the gaussian
with what's on fixed
uh
yeah so i'll explain this a bit more
later but uh if we call this quantity m0
for the one start parameter then using
an appropriate gaussian then
you can get a initialization with m zero
satisfying
kappa to the d over two
yes okay so the scale is exponentially
in the dimension our result
uh scales
is a poly
log m0
so you can see like uh with this
initialization our result is going to
incur extra factors of the of the
dimension
that makes sense thank you so much
all right so
now i'm going to talk about like the
i'll give you like a proof sketch of
this result
so i'm going to start with sort of like
basics about
markup chain
mixing so this to do this i need to
introduce the idea of conductance okay
so let capital t denote the probability
kernel of the algorithm mala and the
conductance of this chain is going to be
defined as this ratio it's like
if given any subset s i'm going to look
at how much mass is flowing from s to s
complement and i'm going to normalize it
by the the mass that pi puts on s
so what this definition is looking at is
it's looking for the presence of
bottlenecks in your space
so for instance if my space looks
something like this
then it would take a really long time
for this markov chain to mix because
it'd be hard for you to get across these
two components so that's essentially
what this definition is capturing and
there's some classical theory triggers
inequality which relates the conductance
to the spectral gap and via this you can
convert this lower balance on the
conductance into
markov chain mixing time results
in particular the mixing time is going
to be like 1 over the conductance
squared
for our result we need a slight
generalization of this which is just s
conductance
so in s conductance the main difference
is that i impose a lower bound on the
probability of events that i'm
considering essentially like the only
events i care about now are are those
that
are sufficiently probable under pi and
this lets us like not have to worry
about events that will kind of never
happen under time
okay um
so with this definition you can still
show and this is a result of lovation
nova it's that you can still bound the
mixing time via the s conductance where
this parameter s has to be taken to be
the accuracy divided by the warm start
parameter
this will i guess become more important
later
so now that i introduced conductance
like the the main question for proving
mixing time balance for markov chains is
how do we lower bound the conductance
and this is kind of a standard lemma
that's used to
lower bounded conductance what it says
is that if i can prove that for all
pairs of points x and y uh which are
distance at most r from each other if i
can get a bound on this tv distance
between t x and t y
okay so t x is
this is the kernel started at x
and similarly for t y
okay if i can bound this tv distance
then it implies a lower bound on the
conductance
so i'll just give you a quick uh
intuition about why this is true so
so remember that conductance is about
encouraging like mixing across these
cuts so suppose i have some cut sns
complement okay the first step is just
going to be
we use some isoparametry
property of pi
so it's a well known that if pi is
strongly log concave then it's going to
satisfy some isopremetry properties what
isopremetry is going to imply is that
most of the mass under pi is going to
lie near the cut
so
near i guess the boundary of the cut
like in this region
pi is going to put most of its mass
there
now uh
this is by the way where where this
comes in this alpha is the strong well
concavity constant
so that's where we use use that property
of time
now the second step is just the
assumption of the lemma
so the assumption of the lemma says that
if i have two points x and y that that
are close to each other then the tv
distance is bounded by three fourths
so let's say i had two points here
this was x and this is y
and they're they're within distance at
most are from each other
then i claim that this assumption of
dilemma implies that x has to send mass
to s complement and y has to send mass
to s so it has to mix
well why is that like imagine if x only
set mass to
s and y only set mass to s complement
then the tv distance between the kernels
would be one rather than
bounded by three fourths as long as
okay so this assumption of dilemma
encourages mixing across the cuts
okay so we had this um
this conductance lemma we need a again a
slight generalization of this to
to lower bound the s conductance rather
than the actual conductance working with
s conductance uh the nice thing is that
we don't really need to check this this
condition for all pairs of points x y we
only need to check them for pairs of
points x y which
are like high probability under the
distribution pi
so this is now going to be our goal is
to bound this overlap which is just a tv
distance between gx and and ty
okay so how do you bound this um
well this is the the standard ways that
you use the triangle inequality and you
bring in q which is the proposal kernel
okay so now we have these three terms
this middle term which is just bounding
the overlap between the proposal kernel
this is actually very easy to bound
okay if you think about what the
longevity proposal is it's just a
gaussian distribution centered at some
point so this is like the
tv distance between two gaussians and
it's like straightforward to control
the real difficulty is how do we control
the first and third terms which are
bounding the difference between t and q
let me just remind you that q here
this is the proposal
and t which is the
kernel of the algorithm
this is the
proposal plus the accept reject
filtering step
the difference between t and q it's
really just
capturing the effect of this filter in
other words it implicitly contains
information about the acceptance
probability of your chain in order to
upper bound this tv distance you kind of
need to lower bound the acceptance
probability of your chain
indeed that's sort of where the previous
analyses got stuck is because uh
it was hard to control this acceptance
probability by hand unless you take the
step size quite small in fact even the
diffusion scaling literature that i
mentioned earlier what they rely on is
like a seven
seventh order tailor expansion of the
acceptance probability and careful
control to to get their
results okay but like the acceptance
probability is a fundamental part of
this algorithm like you can't really run
away from it at some point in your
analysis of it you have to confront the
acceptance property
or do you
so now i'm going to talk about the the
new idea that we introduced to to
analyze this chain
and it rests on this projection
characterization of bilera and diaconus
and what it says is that
if i have here
this is going to be the space of all
reversible markov chains
with stationary distribution pi
then this
metropolis hastings kernel t
this is actually the projection of the
proposal kernel onto this space
with respect to some appropriate metric
that i'm not really going to
describe here
okay and in particular what that means
is if i had another
another kernel q bar here
then it's only farther away from q
than t is
okay so that was a bit informal but
precisely what this theorem implies is
that i can bound this tv distance
between t and q
in terms of the tv distance between q
and q bar
now there's an extremely natural choice
of q bar for this problem because mala
the proposal was obtained as a
discretization of the continuous time
language process
so i'm actually going to take q bar to
be the continuous time range of n
process run for time h
and this is indeed a reversible markov
chain with stationary distribution pi
okay so now we just have to bound the
difference between q and q bar
and this
this reduces the study of mala
to
a pure question
in discretization
how close is the discretization of
langevin from
the langevan itself
why do you have this truth
why do i have a two here so this is kind
of a technical point having to do with
what the distance is that this theorem
is talking about and the fact that t is
an atom
but it's like it won't really matter for
for this talk because uh
we just have to control these terms
anyway so it just ends up being another
constant factor
okay so there's one loose end here that
uh which is that
precisely this statement i wrote here
it only controls this tv distance and
expectation whereas we really need it
with high probability
okay but this can be handled we
we prove a
an extension of this projection theorem
where here like
now you give me any increasing convex
function fee and i can bound the
expectation of phi
of the tv distance between t and q in
terms of point a's involving only q and
q bar
so with the presence of this convex
function now you can write down some
concentration inequalities
so for um i guess for experts like you
might see like how to complete this
argument like if i wanted to bound this
tv distance i can bound it by the tail
divergence
then you can use your sonoff theorem
from stochastic calculus
and you can bound it essentially by a
term that looks like this
and this turns out to just be of order h
squared d
it turns out the kl divergence is not
quite enough for our purposes we need to
balance something stronger but anyway
the tool is still gerson of theorem and
standard arguments of discretization
and what this h squared d tells you is
that in order to control this term you
need to take the step size h
to be smaller than
one over square root d
and this is where our mixing time comes
from for mama
okay quick recap um
so we've improved the dimension
dependence from d
uh to square root d under this extra
assumption of a warm star in the process
we introduced this new technique for
studying these metropolis these things
chains which just like reduces down to
classical questions of discretization of
stochastic processes which is much more
well understood
okay so um there's a couple of questions
that arise from this
the the most obvious question is
we had this extra assumption of having a
warm start can this assumption be
removed and as i mentioned um before
like
if the only thing i tell you about pi is
that it's strongly well concave and lock
smooth then the this warm start
dependence introduces extra factors of
dimension in the bounds so it's uh
undesirable
and another question is like is our
analysis tight can you do even better
than squared
both of these questions were sort of uh
answered in later works or at least like
later works started to address these
questions
there's this paper by yin tatli roti
shen and kevin chan
kevin will be speaking about this like
right after
right after this talk actually
and what it shows is that there exists
initializations such that the warm start
parameter is exponential indeed
such that mala when you initialize with
that that distribution the mixing time
is lower bounded by d
so what does this tell us this tells us
that warm start
is actually necessary
to get our improved rates of auto
square root d
okay and this is a little bit
fundamental like the reason why we're
able to get these improved rates is
because we take an aggressive choice of
step size
now this choice of step size is fine if
you're close to pi
but if you happen to start far away from
pi
this choice of step size will lead you
to rejecting a lot of your steps and
then you'll incur like a poor mixing
time about on firm up really the
the thing to do here is not try to
remove the assumption of warm start from
our analysis but rather like find ways
to algorithmically produce a warm star
and this isn't a hopeless task there are
some actually like promising approaches
for getting this arm start
algorithmically but it's still sort of
like work in progress
i also mentioned that uh
there's a yuan sees talk later in this
workshop on thursday
and
there the the claim is that
kappa times square root d is the tight
rate
for mala under one star
i'm very excited to to hear this talk
and
i guess this would imply that our
analysis is tight under in this form
strategy
okay so
i've talked about our results for mala
in particular i talked a little bit
about what's known about lower bounds
for mala
but it'd be really great if we could do
something beyond just a algorithmic
algorithm specific lower bound and say
something about all sampling algorithms
so that's what i'll try to talk about
next but um i i won't be really able to
give you more than just a short teaser
of this stuff
okay so
here's the the question which is can we
prove lower complexity balance for
example this is uh yes you have a
question
just um
to understand better um
so even with the volume sort you can
it's a d to the one third
right
that you're saying
basically your work and the lower bounds
show that you cannot get it right yeah
so this due to the one third actually
has some like stronger assumptions like
higher order regularity so my current
feeling is that the these higher these
like extra assumptions enable like a
faster rate
so this question of lower complexity
balance for sampling this is an analogy
to this theory of oracle complexity and
optimization which was initiated in
seminal work by nemourovsky and yuden
and
i hope that it's sort of clear like why
we want to look at this lower bound
question like this lower bound question
besides characterizing the fundamental
difficulty of this task of sampling
without it also helps us with algorithm
algorithm design
if we don't really have any lower bounds
and we'll never really know if our our
current algorithms are optimal or not
so there have been some efforts towards
this question but none of them have
really directly answered this this
question
let me just briefly describe
so there's a family of of papers on
algorithm-specific lower bounds i
already talked about a bit about mala
there's this paper by kawalu and wang
which gives a lower bound for how well
you can discretize a specific stochastic
process
so i fix a process like over damped
lunge von process or under damp plunge
fun process and this word tells me how
close can i come to actually simulating
the
that stochastic process
but um this doesn't really tell us if
that stochastic process itself is
optimal and it doesn't really give lower
bounds for other algorithms such as mala
or hmc or whatnot
okay so that's um algorithm specific
works
there's this paper by chatterjee
bartlett and long and what they do is
they give tight rates for this this
complexity question but with a
stochastic gradient oracle rather than
actual gradient oracle
so their lower bound is uh mostly about
overcoming the noise of the stochastic
gradient oracle and therefore it doesn't
really give a lower bound for the
original sampling question
and finally we have this paper by uh
rankingly and john fung wu
on estimating that they give a lower
bound on estimating the normalizing
constant of a probability distribution
but it turns out that this lower bound
doesn't actually imply any lower bound
for the sampling task itself
so in short there
wasn't really any
works
directly for for this question
before our work so now i'll describe
like
our our progress towards this question
which is we managed to characterize the
query complexity of sampling in one
dimension
and we find that the the tight rate is
log kappa
okay so a couple of remarks about this
result so
specifically our performance criterion
is being able to sample to within one
over 64 in tv distance this is sort of
an arbitrary number
our lower bound holds for any kind of
local oracle in particular like the
upper bound is achieved only using
potential queries and all the higher
derivatives are don't really help you
for this problem
and our upper bound is uh achievia
rejection sampling algorithm
so i'll just briefly describe like
what's the strategy of the
of the proof so we construct a family of
distributions
um
holographic p
with the following two properties the
first property is if i have an algorithm
that will output a single sample from a
distribution in this family this single
sample is already enough for you to kind
of identify what distribution you're
sampling from
and what this allows us to do is it lets
you reduce
the task of sampling
to a statistical estimation problem they
made that of estimation of
b itself
now the the second requirement which is
much trickier is to ensure that each
oracle query only reveals all one bits
of information about
the identity of p itself
and what this does is this gives you a
lower bound
on the estimation problem
so taken together these two parts give
you uh information during lower bound on
the the task of sampling
and this like argument structure is is
pretty standard uh in info theory but
the the hard part of course is actually
doing this construction
i'll just uh briefly like flash what
this construction looks like
i've plotted here like the second
derivative of the potential
it's oscillating between the minimum and
maximum allowable values which are 1 in
kappa here
and if i integrate this once to plot
what the the first derivative of this
potential looks like it would look
something like it starts off with one
slope and then goes higher
and so on it looks looks like this uh
staircase shape
and the the reason why we need this kind
of construction is
uh if you have this is just like one
distribution in the family now if i take
another distribution in the family
then it would also like have this
staircase shape and it would kind of
interlace and then at some point
you and we need to make sure that this
second distribution agrees exactly with
the first distribution
the reason why we want to do this is we
want to make sure that each query to the
oracle doesn't leak too much information
about which distribution we're sampling
from
now i won't be able to say
much more about the lower bound here
let me discuss a couple of open
questions so i already discussed this
problem of of the warm start which we're
currently investigating
uh it'd be interesting to see like if
our techniques can be used to analyze
other metropolis hastings algorithms and
another question i find quite
interesting is whether we can
metropolize other algorithms in
particular non-reversible and cmc
for lower bounds then the main question
here is like what is actually the
complexity of sampling can we take our
lower bound in one dimension and extend
it to a lower bound in d dimensions pin
down the complexity there and
maybe look at the complexity of other
classes
this i think is
sort of a key challenge for the field
but
so far like there hasn't been that much
progress but i'm kind of hopeful that we
can make something happen this semester
and uh
finally like a quick plug so i'm
co-organizing this complexity of
sampling working group here at simon's
we've been meeting on tuesdays and
fridays
so if any of these like complexity
questions i brought up today are of
interesting to you then you should um i
guess like you can email me and i'll
send you like a zoom link
and we can like try to like meet and
discuss problems
so we have a wiki
which contains like recordings of
previous meetings and in particular like
this 1d lower bound i spoke about it in
one of these meetings and it's recorded
so if you're
curious about learning more of that you
could see the recording there
yeah that's that's all i have um
i'll take any other questions you have
so about the lower bound it's this is
for any oracle right it doesn't use
i i didn't get exactly what what uh what
are the oracles you're
talking about for the lower bound
um essentially our lower bound would
apply to any kind of oracle that returns
local information about the potential
around the the point that you query for
instance like the value of the potential
and like the value of its derivatives
and so forth
in particular like it applies to an
oracle that returns the value of the
potential the value of the first
derivative and the second derivative at
that point
okay
yeah so
it doesn't imply
it might be much more conservative than
uh
than an oracle that uses first for sort
of information right so it might be
much worse the result for
i'm not quite sure because like the
oracle i'm considering like it can
return first order information right so
the oracle gives you more information so
if you have a lower bound against that
then you have a stronger lower bound yes
yeah
any questions
uh can i ask a question
yes please
um so in the proof um the the previous
proof assuming one start where actually
you exactly using the warm start in the
proof
uh where where did we use the wormstar
in the proof of mala so actually like
this entire conductance machinery that
i've been talking about it all like uses
warm start
so like uh maybe a different question to
ask would be like in these results that
i talked about about the non-essential
results and they they actually don't
need to assume that you have a warm
start like how do they not have a warm
start assumption and the reason why is
that they they like um augment this like
conductance machinery with this like
with this like extra conductance profile
technique um they and like a stronger
isobarimetry property of the
target distribution
and using these like what they're able
to do is that they're able to get a log
log dependence on the warm star
parameter if you start off with one shot
parameter kepler to the d over two then
this log log dependence on the warm
start only introduces extra logarithmic
factors in d
but those techniques uh we can't really
combine them with with our work
because like actually we have lower
bounds against what's possible to do
under
thanks
thank you other questions
okay if not let's thank cinto again
and the next stop will be in 10 minutes
by kevin tien so we'll come back here at
2 50.